this is right
[Laughter]
the tempo just you know it's not like it
that's enough
oh this works well yeah it's oh that
guys let's try this one
yeah just try it out I'm sure it works
dude cartwheel
who did it
keep on keep on you ready yeah I'm ready
check this save look at this
water break water break water break
thank you good let's go let's go come on
why
okay so let's finish them
if you catch it you get 10 dog biscuits
yes yes
but it's actually quite handy to handle
there
first hard and then slow
super bouncy ball straight in the face
[Laughter]
it wasn't even close just throw the
Cucumber at me I know are you sure this
is the best option best option no option
yes
oh perfect so it's working now we know
it's working cucumber blood well done
guys
just like my meatballs
yes we call it
well done because yeah great we call it
ah it goes seven yeah
[Applause]
everybody because everybody Professor
three
okay
you have a really big table and one more
Infinity note is enough you can just use
the simple hack that's actually true so
I think we found some pretty good use
cases uses we used mythical
I need to prepare myself you know you've
got to see where the ball is coming keep
an eye on the ball
you ready I think so
I wasn't even ready for that
stop stop micromanaging get more pop on
yourself
heads or tails tails
you serve okay
there's mental support
whenever someone hit subscribe at the
office we're daily
smashing the gong all the time we're
following the follow account every time
someone subscribes it's a nightmare but
it's worth it I'm not really sure about
this one but let's try
[Music]
my biggest chocolate like
and we're gonna make the biggest
chocolate bracket ever made out of
chocolate ping pong rocket chocolate
bracket you heard it yeah okay no you
know what to do
oh no no no
questions
can we have one each for sympathy
the zero one because that's how I feel
about myself
Venice Beach Skate Park Skate Park
Venice Beach Skate Park
oh
he broke the chair I was just testing if
the bench works okay I think I'm done
with this
one zero player Corner scores
[Laughter]
okay let's go
this is pretty intimidating
around 100 if you're watching this I'm
available for a few million
[Laughter]
[Applause]
where is he
I will do it now I will do it now
walking down the Santa Monica Pier
pretty awesome you should always check
on the table tennis tables before you
start playing because it might be crazy
ax man
we need some dance moves from Mika
[Applause]
one shot did not miss his chance to blow
it's opportunity gone
wow oh this one was wet
foreign
never felt that much pressure with such
a bad surf sorry
[Music]
all good okay let's see who has the best
touch for some balls
I would have made it for the second one
as well five more
[Music]
[Applause]
four more
stay tuned
and this is the one
oh no one
go
guys remember to hit subscribe you can
see the Subscribe button here right here
okay
[Music]